cues are long outside vaccination
centers in the outskirts of the mexican
capital
on monday health officials rolled out
the second phase of mexico's national
inoculation program
i feel happy after receiving the vaccine
i'm glad they brought us the vaccine
they say that with the vaccine hopefully
we can control the pandemic
because too many of our poor brothers
and sisters have left us
after weeks of delays some 870 000
doses of the astrazeneca covid19 vaccine
arrived in the mexican capital over the
weekend restarting the country's stalled
vaccination efforts
what we're witnessing today is the
arrival of the first astrazeneca
vaccines
developed with oxford they were produced
in india
for mexico this shipment is very
important because it will let us
accelerate our vaccination drive
as was ordered by the president
mexico's military has been mobilized to
deliver new doses of the vaccine to all
32 mexican states
[Music]
mexico is nearing two million confirmed
cases and ranks third in the world in
covet 19
deaths the latest shipments of vaccines
are arriving at a critical time
health officials have got the vaccine
they arrived in the morning and they
will continue arriving on tuesday
and they won't stop arriving the
national immunization plan won't stop
as we have said there is preference for
the elderly
while this second phase of the
vaccination program will focus on the
elderly and frontline health workers
the government has also placed top
priority on rural areas
where rates of transmission are
relatively low
many health policy experts say this is
the wrong strategy
adding that the government should be
focused on inoculation efforts
in densely populated cities where
authorities continue to struggle to curb
contagion
mexico's vaccination program began in
december of last year
since then mexico's president has said
the government intends to vaccinate the
entire population that's more than 126
million people
by march of 2022 manuel rapalo al
jazeera
mexico city